where's my resources at
4120s at Tennessee
319ers coming up to around the bridge
[Music]
I got one car between us possibly armed
multiple 69s
since I get a couple units with me we're
coming up to Martin now we're in the
fast lane
so they get a couple units
all right
traffic
[Applause]
challenge
contact
s
all right guys y'all get ready
thank you
foreign
logo on it
hey brother
you hurt
you
don't know where you heard it
yeah roll over
here
all right here stand up over here and
Patch it down you got any weapons on you
no sir nothing at all
right
she's over here
42.50 so six they're telling us there's
somebody under the house
hey Sheriff's Office let me see your
hands
listen I'm telling you listen if you
listen it's gonna go easy come right out
to me
yes you can
come on
come out stop reaching man I can't see
your hand
S no move out of his way get out of his
way get out of his way he tucked his
hand get out of the way
I can see one both hands both hands both
hands keep coming
keep coming
out
keep coming keep crawling on out man
you're doing something on your belly on
your belt on your belly on your face
all right do you have any weapons on you
no no handcuffed teeth someone check
this
weapons I'm gonna slide you to your
right I'm gonna just make sure you got
nothing on this okay I got money on me
in my bag I'll make sure you keep that
money all right
yeah I got it come on
thank you